hello guys chris p and welcome back to
another video today my friends i'm gonna
be testing the rx 560
in early 2021. this one is a four
gigabyte model of the card
you can see that it's from sapphire uh
it's the pulse
itx i think maybe pulse only a version
of the card yeah the cooler is pretty
small on it as you can see it's just
that
aluminium thingy right there oh does it
play music actually
holy crap this is beautiful anyways my
friends this is a 75 watt card so it
doesn't really need a beefy cooler
and it does the job pretty well it does
require a six pin power connector but i
think there are a few models of the 560
that don't require
any power connector at all um i might be
wrong on that but i don't know like 75
watts you can get that
through the motherboard's pci express
connector you know now four years ago
you could grab this graphics card for
a hundred bucks that was its msrp 99 us
dollars
and now uh in 2021 i think you can find
it for like 150 bucks 130 and
it's just everything is horrible my
friends
the market is absolutely ridiculous
if you buy one of these please make sure
to buy it for like
what 50 bucks or lower i wouldn't pay
more than that for a used rx 560 at
least okay
so let's go ahead and install this in
the system
and see what it can do in early 2021
shall we and here we go my friends we're
now in the desktop as you can see rx 560
is showing up there in ms afterburner as
well as the radian settings
this one is the four gig variant as i
told you i'm running it with a ryzen 9 5
900 x and 32 gigs of ram which is
kind of a little bit overkill you know
but it doesn't matter we're only testing
the gpu here but let's get into our
first game which is going to be
the worst optimized game ever cyberpunk
and here we are we're playing at 720p
resolution using the low settings preset
low textures because although we have
four gigs of vram
i just don't really feel comfortable
increasing that with the 560 you know
high crowd density because it's a cpu
intensive option and
we don't really have a problem with that
you know 40
30 sometimes it's not too bad
but i wouldn't really buy this game
within rx 560. if you want to play this
you better
upgrade your gpu because i just feel
like this
is just way too low for cyberpunk you
want to experience those visuals
you want to get at least like 30 plus
all of the time and i think it will drop
from 30 in
intensive areas oh god oh god what am i
doing no no no no i didn't want to oh
gosh
our frames guys i think it's performing
worse than before
what is going on with this game it's so
broken it's not even funny guys
this game is horrible in terms of
optimization
yeah this is way too bad this is like
gtx 760 kind of performance which
you know it's kind of yeah in the
ballpark i guess this is just way too
low look at that
look at that this is complete crap guys
don't buy this game with the rx 560 okay
i
i actually expected a lot better than
this to be honest i think it was
performing better
in earlier versions of the game you know
so
wow guys at cd projekt red what the heck
are you doing with this
you know what i'll play this game
through in like two years time
i think by then it should be actually
doable so yeah let's get to the next one
okay let's play some call of duty
warzone right now we're playing it at
the 720p resolution
low settings low texture as well
everything else set to the lowest
settings because this is what it takes
for it to get 60 plus fps basically
oh boy i really didn't expect up to like
90 fps
in open areas like this one this is
actually pretty decent
okay let's drop in the downtown area go
to that very demanding little street
with the fire effects and smoke effects
and stuff and uh
yeah that that should be a good
benchmark here i really hope i don't die
right away
yeah there are a lot of people dropping
here oh boy okay we got to start
counting our fps
70 around here so we lose a few frames
by not being in an open field obviously
but
it's pretty good still you know this is
actually really nice
and i would play at 720p low settings
now i'm actually playing against
full squads of four so this is this kind
of bad you know let me just go this way
i don't know but last time that i tested
this game
i think it was closer to 60 than
80 like we're getting 79 fps average so
far
i just want to see the smoke effects
come on okay
we're fine all right so near the fire as
you can see
60s this is really good this means that
it won't really drop from 60 frames here
throughout the gameplay what the what
the why oh
okay why two of them what is go what is
are those uavs now you can see the uavs
oh
what the heck did they just don't stop
go
i just gotta say guys i've been walking
around for a little bit
and this is really really smooth like
it doesn't drop from 60 even here
looking at the entire city as you can
see it gets close to 60
but it doesn't drop from it now there's
a bad thing about the e720p resolution
and that's
uh i you can't really see things at the
distance
so you'll be at a little bit of a
disadvantage but i think it's worth the
trade-off 60 plus fps in these games
is absolutely great grenade
oh my gosh what is going on oh boy okay
yeah i i i could i was really confused
there horizon zero dawn will it play
well with this gpu this game was
actually
really really intensive when it came out
or kind of really really broken i guess
but
yeah we're playing at 1080p with the low
settings and uh
i think it has been optimized to the
point where
it's kind of playable at these settings
with the rx 560 if you want closer to
60fps you can always drop it down to
720p
that's actually how i initially intended
to test this game 720p
low settings but after seeing 60fps i
thought
well let's just go for 1080p because
this is a single-player title
you don't really need 60fps all of the
time and actually a 30fps experience
at 1080p might be a little bit better
than 720p at low
let's just fight these big boys right
here this is not a good idea it's never
a good idea but
uh yeah okay boy what the heck just
happened all right we got some fire
effects going on
if it doesn't drop from 30 i will be
impressed because it's
really really close to it oh i gotta
craft more arrows let's go let's go you
know what
it's holding up fine considering that we
are actually fighting this
big boy and it's not dropping from 30
god damn it jesus
oh that was kind of close uh where's the
other one
by the way the 4 gig variant of this
card will do a much better job here in
horizon zero dawn compared to the
two gig cards nothing to see here what
no there's a lot of things to see here
like beautiful lens flares look at that
my friends if you want to experience
this you can with the rx 560 it doesn't
look too bad at low settings either
oh my god okay okay that was really fast
okay my friends next game up is gta 5
the gorgeous game from 2015 that
sometimes
actually looks better than newer games
i'm not gonna name any but
yeah anyways we are playing at 1080p
using
the uh very high settings actually as
you can see some things are not set to
the
the highest settings like the grass
quality post effects tessellation as
well advanced settings all turned off
and this time around i'm actually gonna
go with this car
right here electric pink and green car
look at that it looks kind of sexy
doesn't it my friends
i already screwed it up god damn it
now god why why don't people check their
mirrors in this game
oh boy oh boy okay we're fine we're fine
the handling is
nice ish i'm not sure if it's gonna be
able to
uh actually drive up the hill you know
what so far so good
66 fps average there pretty good stuff
get out please this is what happens with
cars that don't make any noise
it also happens with other cars but
still people get out people come on
no okay oh boy all right all right it's
all good
so good the car is not really that
beautiful
anymore but uh okay come check cut
you bastards dropping into the 40s guys
come on buddy we can do it we can do it
oh hello my beautiful boy how's it going
friend
it's been like a day actually i've been
testing gta 5 quite a bit last week so
uh where is he where he's running he's
always running away from me
it is very very playable it looks great
at 1080p
and i would play like this holy crap
how how the heck did that happen friends
we're now playing rainbow six siege
using i got five seconds to do this so
1080p resolution 90 fov
low settings as you can see 100 render
scaling
we're also utilizing the vulcan api
so that that was quite the post cover
not gonna lie
all right here we go we started outside
which is good because
this is where you're gonna see the least
fps outside of houses
what should we do my friends i don't
really want to die right away
gosh don't do that to me buddy
okay seriously though i'm playing
newcomer and caveira does that pose and
instantly kills my drone
this guy has a hole in the wall and
this doesn't feel like newcomer anymore
this guy even knew that there was a
camera there what the heck is going on
damn bro this guy is a pro sentai is a
pro guys
oh okay santa just kill them all guys
you guys go first i don't even care
anymore i
i just don't want to die in the first
five seconds
so inside of houses as you can see you
get above 100 fps
oh boy okay ghost is killing them
assassin is killing them
that is good i'm just gonna go ahead and
do this i'm helping see
i got him i got him i got a last one
nice
got one okay that was decent
we did something there there's one of
them okay get over here boy i got you i
got you buddy get out of there oh god
damn it dude
oh oh oh
yeah i got another one okay i'm doing it
i'm doing it 104 fps average i messed
that up but
it was really smooth the experience is
great here in rainbow six siege
time for another really intensive title
this is assassin's creed valhalla 720p
100 resolution scale using the low
settings um no boy i don't
really know yet this is this is pretty
much the same
as what we got in my previous rx 560
video so
nothing really changed here
unfortunately
uh low 40s high 30s maybe
i didn't really see it dropping into the
30s but the one percent lows
say that we dropped to 39 but yep it
might be a little bit wrong i don't know
explosions if you really want to play
this game the 560 will do a good job
those stuttering issues are mostly fixed
by now oh gosh damn it i'm on fire you
know what that 720p
doesn't really look that good but i
guess
it could be playable for someone that
really
really wants to experience assassin's
creed valhalla you know all right
outside of little towns you can expect
around 70 fps
60 plus experience you know not too bad
i wouldn't really pay
60 dollars for a game to run like this
in my opinion of course so just wait for
a sale or something the 560 can run it
it's just
okay time to play some rust we're
playing it at 1080p resolution using
these settings these are like uh medium
to high
i guess uh ambient occlusion is enabled
because
it makes a huge difference on how this
game looks and as you can see it's
looking pretty good
you know this guy sleeping there let's
visit him
i'm gonna start counting our friends see
he just woke up okay
he might actually kill us so i'm i'm
gonna go this way then
now the areas where we're gonna see the
least fps are basically banded camp
and very dense forest areas so i'm gonna
try to find one of those
now the thing with rust is you don't
need
60 fps all of the time you know i am
perfectly happy with like
40 plus fps most of the time with a
slight drop here and there
into the 30s and i i would prefer to
play it on
higher graphical settings because it
really looks impressive
whenever you bump up those graphics so
basically it runs really well
i i got no issues with this experience
right here fps
dropped by a little bit there the one
percent lows because of the inventory
tab
but yeah 46 fps on average is pretty
decent let's play some cs go now shall
we
1080p resolution using the low settings
with high textures
all right guys let's start counting
those frames per second and
uh here we are my friends we're getting
300 right now
okay okay there we go
oh oh come on i missed the flick there
why is everybody with a knob guys oh boy
okay
oh oh come on they're everywhere now
i couldn't really see them earlier but
now they're absolutely
everywhere
there's another orc there's another one
i think yep there is okay got him nice
what are you doing here what the heck
okay
what are you guys doing just camping
here in teamspawn looking at mid doors
seriously guys that's how you want to
play deathmatch
i kind of sucked in this one but uh i
blame the ping
as always you never admit you suck at
csgo okay
it's time for apex legends we're playing
it at 1080p resolution
using the low settings with medium
textures i
like to have a little bit of breathing
room you know okay this is not really
looking that promising
as you can see 30s what do we have here
nothing special no weapon yeah weapon
okay you've got the weapons i don't get
anything good stuff buddy
anyways most intensive area in this map
we're getting 55 fps
now of course i recommend 60 plus fps
all of the time in a game like this
and for that you can easily drop the
resolution to 720p
and get that experience i actually have
videos testing the rx 516 apex legends
and
it does a pretty good job at 720p all
right let's see the fps looking at the
city from above
60 okay right at the edge of playability
for a competitive shooter like this
i wish i had like a sentinel or
something oh boy there's one right there
did you see me yep he did
oh boy okay yep this is this wasn't a
good idea
give me a long range weapon game come oh
thank god
nice okay now we just need oh oh
no no no no no okay all right oh boy oh
boy oh boy
okay we got this we got let's go after
him and to help our guy here
oh gosh why why did you die buddy no oh
man
fps are dropping considerably there not
liking this too much
let's go buddy let's go buddy let's go
buddy let's go buddy i got this i got
this we got this
yes we made it we made it oh no no no no
no no no no
no no okay yep definitely choose to play
this at 7280p because it drops into the
40s very often
oh oh oh they got the wall x on now oh
what the heck is that
crap oh boy
this is bad this is really bad yep okay
okay
guys this is it uh we're gonna lose now
all right all right maybe maybe they got
the wall hex again
we got him we got him up and running oh
my gosh it's
so tough with 40 fps this game ah
and we're now playing red dead
redemption 2 at 1080p resolution
using the balanced preset but uh
keep in mind that the presets actually
change with the graphics card that you
have installed so
the balanced preset for the rx 560 is
not the same
as the balanced preset on a 1050 ti or
rx 570 for example so just just just
remember that okay
don't compare it to another gpu that
i've already tested on balanced preset
so
um here we go this should be enough for
us to get 30 plus fps
all of the time it's actually morning
time right now it's looking
pretty although a lot of things are
actually on low settings
it still manages to look good here you
know i mean even on low settings if you
keep the anti-aliasing and a little bit
of ambient occlusion
it will look good this game is is
gorgeous we're now making our way to
saint denis
oh boy 135 dollars bounty this
is not good and as you can see saint
denis
isn't really that intensive we're
dropping the fps into like the
low to mid 30s at times and yeah the 560
has
no problems playing red dead 2 at 1080p
which is amazing i've actually tested
the xbox one x
settings once in a video and uh
it did pretty well you know around 35
fps average it was slightly lower than
this it might actually drop here and
there from 30
at those settings but you know what it's
perfectly playable you can lock the fps
to 30 play with the controller and
you're gonna get like
a console like experience you know all
right roach roach calm down calm down
boy oh god oh that's oh boy
no roach why why do you have to leave me
between two crocodiles
uh just passing by i really hope that
arthur knows how to swim
never mind it's not gonna be needed okay
you know what for the first time ever in
a pub g video we're gonna go
straight to boot camp okay by the way
we're playing it at 1080p
using 100 resolution scale and very low
settings with medium view distance and
medium textures
let's get out okay that's a that's a lot
of people dropping here with us but i
don't really care we're gonna kill them
all guys especially
with that beautiful packet loss you know
they don't have it so
uh we're in an advantage right now
no no we are not this is kind of bad
right now
our fps are really good i was expecting
less than that to be honest but uh
yeah stutters
seems like they broke pope g now uh it
was running really smoothly
the last time well not the last time
around because the last time around
i played with that laptop that had an
hd7970m
and it was very stuttery and it seems
like it is
kind of stuttery um
again oh boy okay
now how the heck how the heck did that
miss and why does it
explode what the heck
well we're gonna go away oh my god what
the hell that was really loud um
i just i just want some decent weapon
please
do you josh damn bastard come over here
boy
oh do you have what what
what no no what's this what's the melee
key
you know what since i love pubg so much
i i'm not even gonna repeat that
it's playable but they broke the game
again
like how do you do that it was running
so smoothly like a month ago
so i wasn't really gonna test fortnite
for this video because the game is
completely broken when it comes to
stuttering
issues but it's it's actually not too
bad so this is the next morning
1080p resolution epic view distance so
these are competitive settings directx
12 api
oh my god just look at those trees why
oh my gosh okay okay everything is fine
now
we're going to the most gpu intensive
area in this map which is
um the weeping woods i'm
oh no oh okay wait a second i i don't
want to die oh boy
oh okay all right we're fine we're fine
it wouldn't be the first time that i die
with
a tree like that you know it's actually
pretty smooth now
in direct x12 i'm liking this they they
actually
fixed it finally but yeah just running
around the whipping woods it seems like
we're averaging around like 100 fps
sometimes it goes above that
when you're inside of houses and stuff
but yeah
outside around 100 fps is what you
should expect which is pretty good
inside of bush's 85 fps 8285 i guess
not bad this isn't really high refresh
rate experience like it used to be
with the rx 560 but it is great you know
what's not great my skills in this game
there are still a couple of stutters not
sure if you saw that one
yeah desert areas are always easy to run
so we get a ton of fps around here
oh there are guys over there okay okay
okay uh you can do it buddy he's level
oh i'm shooting my own guy
what the heck was that crisp oh boy oh
boy
oh boy okay okay yep you know what maybe
oh
behind now
well guys i i just completely suck at
fortnite these days
okay this is watchdogs legion now we're
playing it at 720p
using adfov and the low settings i
might be underestimating this gpu a
little bit but let's see
okay this is this ain't too bad you know
let's steal this
cops car he just he got out of the
okay then that's how you steal cop cars
guys uh so
it seems like it's a a smooth experience
here okay it's performing a little bit
better than what i
expected um i was kind of aiming for
like 40-ish fps on average but it seems
like we are above
50. i don't think police cares too much
about me you know
oh people are are getting out of the way
because i got a cop car
oh my god i need i need to do this more
often oh look at those lens flares those
are actually
extremely beautiful actually i'm not
sure what i said there but
okay so yeah it's it's dropping into the
40s more often right now because we're
near the river and although they have
fixed those
water issues here in watchdogs legion
it's still
not completely like at 100 because it
still drops for no reason near water
it's not as much as before because
before it was dropping into the low
uh 30s and high 20s even but it still
drops
which is kind of weird why is water that
looks like crap
more intensive than this beautiful city
of london i
i don't get it i really don't get it you
know what guys i really like those lens
flares look at that
i i don't know why i i love lens flares
in games
except in battlefield 3 those were like
absolutely atrocious those were horrible
i have no idea what i'm doing i'm just
driving around clueless
just talking about horizon zero dawn's
lens flares
what the heck and finally for the last
game we got
valorent i really like this game 1080p
resolution using
high settings the ui quality set to low
because
some of you guys actually told me that
this is basically a useless setting that
will drop your fps so i set it to low
we're not utilizing anti-aliasing here
what are you okay okay okay we got this
we ping
i got no it's not pink it's just packet
loss i think sometimes it will go up i
i i'm not sure though uh oh oh i killed
him nice
the guy was low hp i got a little bit
confused but we got an ace straight away
guys
which is kind of interesting it doesn't
happen too often
no not from behind not from behind you
bastard
ha gotcha i knew she was coming for the
health
oh no no i hate it when they come from
behind
you're supposed to run around like call
of duty you know you're not supposed to
just
camp somewhere yeah
oh another ace yes nice
i know there's one there
gosh now of course if you want to get
these fps you'll need
kind of a beefy cpu maybe like a ryzen 3
300x which you would
probably not pair with an rx 560 but you
know what
it's it's it's what the gpu can do this
you know if you don't bottleneck it this
is what you can expect
nope whenever i see people
there's another one that comes from
behind me and kills me like stress
see this god damn it i'm gonna blame it
on the ping again
it's conclusion time and do i recommend
the rx 560
in 2021 i don't recommend it because
in the latest and greatest titles it
struggles quite a bit you know you have
to play at 720p
low settings or medium settings to
actually get
30 plus fps you shouldn't really buy the
560 and it's mostly because the rx 570
exists and it only costs like 20 bucks
more than this usually now in the
current market
well i don't know what the prices are in
your country but
i can still find some rx 570s around 100
bucks
like i've seen one of them a four gig
variant for like 90 euros
recently so you can still grab some rx
570s
at decent prices at least here in
portugal
so that makes the 560 a tough buy you
should only buy this one if you're
interested in playing esports titles
and if you find it for like 50 bucks or
lower because
otherwise for more than 50 bucks you got
way better options something that comes
to mind is for example the rx 470 that
thing is like 10
slower than an rx 570 which is like
twice as fast as this by the way
and it usually costs the same as the 560
because
people just think that 470 560 you know
the 560 might be around the same
performance as the 470
but it isn't like this is a lot slower
that's my recommendation here
you shouldn't buy this it was never
really good value because it was always
above its msrp
and the 570 even new usually only cost
around 20 bucks more so that's been it
my friends thank you very much for
watching this video don't forget to like
and subscribe if you haven't already
i'll catch you guys in the next one very
soon as always love you all
bye bye